just days ahead of us President Donald
Trump's next trip to Europe senior US
officials have renewed threats to pull
US troops out of Germany
if Berlin fails to boost its defense
spending in June Trump suggested moving
the more than 30,000 soldiers stationed
here to Poland but would it really be
that easy for the US military to leave
after decades of military presence here
our reporter Fabien Fonda mark went to
Ramstein the biggest US base in Germany
where most locals want the Americans to
stay a key American outpost in
southwestern Germany Ramstein Air Base
the biggest US Air Force Base abroad
just what takes place there is kept
secret even 70 years after the base was
founded
[Music]
it is impossible to get any closer to
the airbase the entire compound is a
high-security zone and we certainly
weren't allowed to enter the base itself
with a camera team instead the US
military gave us some of their own video
footage from inside Ramstein the US
military shows how munitions and weapons
are stored supplies for fighters in
Syria Mali or Afghanistan paratroopers
practiced jumping fighter pilots set off
from here on their missions to Africa
Asia and the Middle East
defending Germany only plays a smaller
role according to this expert on the US
this is not really of course is a bit of
protection but at the same time
strategic importance of Ramstein for
u.s. foreign policy and security policy
must not be underestimated
Jennsen and it's not just the airbase
the biggest American military hospital
outside continental United States is
also nearby doctors and health care
workers trained here for emergencies and
for working in a war zone wounded
soldiers are brought here from all over
the world soon they will be relocating
not to Poland but closer to the airfield
a new hospital costing around a billion
dollars will be built more modern and
better equipped forests at the edge of
the airbase has already been cleared the
mayor of hamster and fields the large
investment alone means there will be no
move isn't it you never know what will
get used or not but I can't see it
happening our Tod is commerce net force
to the US has also invested a lot in
modern warfare in recent years the Air
and Space Operations Center is located
at the air base it's one of the u.s.
military's data hubs it is now an open
secret that Ramstein and plays a central
role in US drone strikes
important information on targets our
relates to the US via Ramstein opponents
of the base are unhappy about
preparations for war being made in
Germany for them a u.s. withdrawal would
be a reason to celebrate
but most people in Ramstein disagree
Germans and Americans have grown
together over the decades as seen at the
german-american friendship fest among
the guests are form and active members
of the military who don't believe the
airbase will be relocated how a.m. sight
is a central point in Europe for the
whole American forces and not only a
Europe at Africa's Middle East
everything is centered around Ramstein
and that's why this place is gonna stay
here look carefully at the airbase more
than a thousand buildings many of them
underground I know the place for that
reason they can't move at all to Poland
the Trump administration's threats to
relocate are something people in
Ramstein cannot imagine will ever happen
the joint location is too important for
both Americans and Germans let's bring
in our political correspondent Simon
Young here Simon
we just heard for some analysts and
people in Ramstein saying that they
don't believe that that the US will be
pulling its troops out of Germany
anytime soon but what about the
political establishment here in Berlin
do policymakers here take Trump's threat
seriously well certainly Chancellor
Merkel has said that she's not unduly
concerned about this she believes that
American troops are here to stay
and politicians generally point out but
as we saw in that report you know the
u.s. is spending hundreds of millions
every year to support the infrastructure
that these troops need Germany by the
way also spends hundreds of millions on
things related to the US military and
people say you know look these
suggestions that the u.s. might pull
back have been going on for decades but
places like Ramstein have continued to
grow not least because they're central
to the defense not just of Europe but of
the United States as well but does Trump
have a point though with respect to
Germany spending enough on its NATO
defense budget is Germany really
carrying its weight as one of the
strongest economically richest countries
in NATO well in terms of spending
perhaps not because there's a two
percent target that NATO has Germany's
up to one point three six percent so
there's still some way to go there
Germany doesn't like to get involved in
combat missions it's George or not war
war and that's one of the arguments
that's often made in this relation
because Germany says you know we put the
emphasis on supporting civil society and
preventing conflict in conflict regions
and Germany spends a lot of money there
apart from that in recent years Germany
has got involved in all sorts of
overseas military operations their
peacekeeping in in Kosovo their training
in Afghanistan they're doing logistics
in Mali and they're also involved in the
anti is coalition in Iraq and Syria of
course alongside the United States and
these foreign missions we should remind
ourselves have only become possible
since the end of the Cold War in the
1990s politically in Germany now the
NATO 2% spending threshold that's just
one point of contention between Germany
and the US there are many others so many
that Trump has decided not to visit
Germany on his upcoming visit trip to
Europe well that's true
I'm not sure that that's a big problem
Trump did also say recently he's very
happy to come to Germany and and looks
to do that at some point but as you said
there's a lot of tension between the two
partners particularly over the Iran
nuclear deal u.s. has pulled out Germany
says it's still sticking to that plan to
get Iran on side there's also trade
tensions quite important with the Trump
saying you know that he's he's that US
companies are treated unfairly in Europe
while Angela Merkel says she wants a
trade deal between the US and the EU as
soon as possible so there are these
problems
he's also not signed up to the
protection mission that the US is
proposing in the Strait of Hormuz where
Iran has been threatening international
ships and that's another example really
Germany says we want de-escalation we
want diplomacy and we're a bit worried
that Donald Trump might drag us into
some sort of conflict we don't want to
be in Simon thank you so much political
correspondent Simon Young